tu t'es des tu as des regrets sur
celui-là ou pas ok ok
que que n'aimons pas ou qui ne qui ne
comptent pas dans nos vies non non rien
ne nous blesse surtout venant de lui
sûrement pas non par contre on se rend
compte qu'il y a une certaine hypocrisie
on voit bien que le monsieur il est très
au fait de tout ce qui se passe sur nos
réseaux
[Applaudissements]
juste avant
tu as vu comment tu
et toi
calme-toi calme-toi un peu là
madame le rédacteur m'a demandé si mon
fils voulait venir j'ai fait quoi j'ai
été très bien d'ailleurs
incroyable
je dis écoute tu poses la question à Léo
donc je sais pas si tu es où
hello m'a dit oui je veux bien venir
parler en plateau voilà par contre vos
comportements à vous de ont été honteux
ne parlez pas mal parce que Théo m'a
garanti que seul les questions de Cyril
serait adressée à Léo et vous êtes
permis d'attaquer mon fils et ça je ne
tolère pas c'est pas beau
de Raymond justement parce que on a
entendu plein de choses ici et Géraldine
Mathieu normault qui disait mais stop
allons sur un sujet un peu plus un peu
plus élevé il faut être objectif
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur le sujet
je suis venu pour toi
je suis venu pour toi je t'ai dit deux
mots dans le couloir tu te souviens
ouais d'accord maintenant non non non
tu ne peux pas
sérieux on s'amuse plus maintenant
d'accord sinon c'est dans mon bureau à
16h mais on se verra à 16h dans mon
bureau voilà
tu les écoutes pas maintenant on va
parler d'un sujet écoute Raymonde qui
est grave et qui s'appelle les
traumatisés d'accord maintenant d'abord
on va revenir un petit peu sur
l'historique
j'accuse TF1 de prendre des personnes
avec une faille un peu fragile
et de les mettre dans des conditions
dangereuses ça veut dire que toi quand
tu as été sur TF1 moi il y a quelqu'un
qui m'a envoyé la vidéo donc je me suis
tapé tout l'après-midi à écrire à faire
la vidéo et analyser la situation
c'est pour toi Amandine
donc quand TF1 apprend des personnes ne
parle pas quand je parle quand il a faim
tu vas hurler à chaque fois quand TF1
prend des personnes et que la personne
savent que la personne c'est une faille
chez toi une petite faille toi c'est pas
méchant une petite faille voilà
et la petite faille c'est que tu faisais
déjà du libertinage
on n'est pas libertin non j'ai pas dit
liberté
on est exclusif non libérée mais pas
tu vas connaître gloire et beauté ici on
connaît gloire et beauté
c'était parfait et après qu'est-ce qui
se passe dans ta tête après quand tu
quittais enfin qu'est-ce qui se passe à
ce moment-là c'est ça l'histoire ça
commence là ton histoire moi j'ai
visionné la vidéo de qui c'est qui me
l'a envoyé là sur Youtube là je sais pas
quoi
déjà je peux me permettre je peux me
permettre avant de poursuivre sur TF1 on
n'a jamais connu de gloire et beauté on
a toujours été la famille la plus
critiquée non mais d'accord oui mais tu
as été mise en avant
on était là
après
la situation Amandine pour l'instant on
a toujours été un peu voilà vraiment on
va dire une caricature c'est vrai qu'on
a toujours on a toujours été décrié de
par un moi mon caractère celui de mon
mari parce qu'on nous en dit pas l'un de
l'autre néanmoins on a toujours sincère
et honnête et nous-mêmes face au
téléspectateurs donc c'était très on est
d'accord tu as été parfaite vous avez
vraiment elle vous demande ce qui s'est
passé après non mais il faut construire
l'histoire tu comprends oui voilà donc
après après de ce que moi j'ai vu et que
j'ai analysé tout l'après-midi sur la
vidéo
à chaque fois ça va pas y arriver
laisse-moi finir donc donc après
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous allez
découvrir moi ce que j'ai vu sur la
vidéo c'est un couple d'abord qui s'est
passé
voilà d'accord je sais déjà
d'accord mais 5 minutes pour moi oui
donc si tu veux à partir de ce moment-là
moi quand je vois la vidéo je vois un
jeune enfin un jeune ah oui un couple
qui ont une boîte de prod ils ont une
boîte de prod il y a des caméraman il y
a des acteurs d'un seul coup mais écoute
moi Amandine essaie de suivre quand je
parle je sais justement une boîte
c'est-à-dire c'est un truc où tout est
bien organisé vous présenter des
produits c'est pas méchant ce que je dis
ça j'ai dit quelque chose de mal oui
mais on va dire business on va se faire
déchirer on va lui dire tout doucement
hein donc un business ça te va un
business alors qu'est-ce qui alors quand
il y a le début de l'interview vous
montrer les ustensiles comme tu vois
quelqu'un montre à l'aspirateur vous
voyez en fait
laisse-moi analyser parce qu'à la fin il
faut que j'arrive donc
si tu veux moi ce que je vois pour faire
plus rapide je vois quelqu'un un homme
et une femme peu importe qui ont créé
une entreprise boîte de prod on va dire
what the prod c'est plus rigolo
bon d'accord tu changeras après ensuite
et qui présente leurs produits etc etc
parallèlement à ça un couple qui a dû
être un peu éloigné pendant l'histoire
des enfants et qui se retrouvent
d'accord et qui se retrouve donc c'est
positif voilà et et après c'est ça et
après il y a tout un enchaînement où
c'est une situation qui a été créée ça
oui j'aime pas le mot business mais
c'est tu vois c'est quelque chose qui a
été établi on a des commandes on a
beaucoup de commandes ça pourrait oui
mais c'est un business tu vois où les
choses elles sont comme ça bien établies
Géraldine Mathieu hier qui disait
s'il vous plaît c'est insupportable tu
lisez les psy dit je pense que pense que
c'est dramatique pour les enfants
qu'est-ce que vous dites-vous Raymonde
ce que c'est pour ça que je vous inviter
soit je voulais avoir votre réponse
voilà donc tu vois d'un côté il y a le
il y a eu TF1 après il y a le business
et puis après il y a les enfants
d'accord ben alors maintenant
tu veux tu me la donnes merci beaucoup à
la parole écoute-moi 5 minutes je me
fais je me fais laminer il y a 2 jours
je n'étais pas là et hier je me suis
fait insulter devant mon fils par ces
deux énergumènes répondez pas celui-ci
aussi là attendez alors Raymonde
alors les enfants pour les enfants avec
moi Amandine parce que c'est toujours
pas une attention 5 minutes on va pas y
arriver je suis très attentive au
contraire alors on y va les enfants
si on prend les grands schémas de la
psychanalyse tel que moi j'ai pratique
un enfant à qui on dit pas les choses il
peut effectivement voir les images et il
peut être traumatisé maintenant il faut
faire la différence entre un traumatisme
et un choc ici ils ont tous été choqué
tu vois la différence maintenant un
enfant il peut être que c'est traumatisé
ou choqué un choc c'est immédiat il y a
quelque chose tu vois tu réagis
immédiatement un choc
mais on est tous choqué ici mais après
on raisonne tu comprends on est grande
contrairement à toi bon ok donc
maintenant d'accord maintenant les
traumatismes c'est c'est quelque chose
qui se passe qui n'est pas expliqué qui
est sous silence qui est pas dit qui est
pas raconté et qui va faire une espèce
de masse et qui va se réveiller tôt ou
tard c'est à 18 ans 20 ans c'est pas
d'accord maintenant on a quand même du
sexe dans l'histoire donc ça fait une
légère différence donc donc les
traumatismes alors ici tout le monde a
été choqué donc tu dois accepter qu'il
soit choqué
moi je suis des milliers de personnes
qui sont
comportement
c'est une expression
toutes les situations donc si tu assures
vraiment digne les gens disent qu'on
comprend rien c'est quelque chose que tu
vois que tu vois sur lequel tu mets des
paroles etc et tu vas faire une autre
histoire d'accord maintenant si on
explique à un enfant papa maman vont
travailler très tard et rentreront tard
le matin ils peuvent comprendre d'accord
maintenant tu as un enfant qui est grand
qui est dans sa bulle parce que je pense
en plus ça doit être un HP donc il est
dans sa bulle tranquille
oui mon fils est surdoué donc
il est mort sa bulle
insupportable alors on va parler Léo il
s'appelle
alors comme je connais bien les surdoué
le surdoué il va tout donner pour ses
parents il les adore donc quoi que vous
fassiez lui il sera toujours d'accord
avec vous attends non non mais pas
d'accord sur mais quand tu arrêtes pas
de la ramener il peut pas être d'accord
non plus tu comprends alors à un moment
faut être un peu
doucement alors que mon fils il a été
personnel
on s'appellera pour les enfants
tout ce qui n'est pas dit qui n'est pas
expliqué sera vécu comme quelque chose
qui fait une masse dont l'enfant fera
son histoire d'accord évidemment que ça
sera un traumatisme selon selon selon
les événements une mère qui rentre tard
c'est un trauma le père qui bat sa femme
c'est un trauma il y en a plein des
traumas d'accord bien sûr d'accord
maintenant là il y a une petite
différence c'est qu'on est avec une
histoire de sexe tu veux pas dire non
bah oui quand même
j'ai vu des vidéos c'est pas un dessin
animé
il y a quelque chose tu sais par exemple
les parents sont dans la chambre avec un
enfant et l'homme il dit à sa femme
parce que en général c'est l'homme qui a
demandé mais il y a aussi des femmes et
il dit arrête avec moi s'il te plaît
alors je te parle d'autre chose il y a
pas que toi je te parle d'autres cas
d'accord les parents dorment à côté d'un
enfant et ils disent c'est pas grave
l'enfant il dort on fait l'amour c'est
très traumatisant
avec moi c'est pour ça écoute moi cinq
minutes
c'est plus facile que le tien donc si tu
veux c'est ça il y a plein de
traumatismes de voilà maintenant le sexe
c'est quoi c'est visuel c'est les images
qui vont rester c'est pas les paroles
pas beaucoup d'accord donc on est
d'accord c'est les images c'est censé
soit les enfants voilà merci soit bien
avec moi on va donner du sens à ce que
tu fais soit les enfants ils voient les
images et les images ils vont les
stocker dans la mémoire entend bien le
dangereux
c'est pas une chanson
[Rires]
en direct par exemple un enfant
l'image elle va rentrer dans la tête de
l'enfance
un visuel Amandine on va se faire un
schéma l'image
telle qu'elle soit on parlera après
c'est quoi l'image elle va rentrer dans
la tête de l'enfant d'accord il va
grandir il va grandir il va vous les
oreilles
on va dire
insupportable dans la tête de l'enfant
mémorise d'accord après il rencontre une
femme
il y a l'image de sa femme et après il y
a cette image qui vient se superposer et
il sait plus avec qui baise est-ce que
tu comprends le problème oui je crois
que là elle a compris
[Rires]
donc on parle des traumatismes
évidemment ça concerne pas toi tu es
dans ton business mais tu dois venir
avec moi sur la route toi Raymonde
est-ce que tu penses donc toi
tu penses que c'est traumatisant pour
les enfants je pense que les images elle
reste marqué elle a beau avoir expliqué
j'aimerais bien attendre Alexandre un
peu Alexandre qu'est-ce que tu en penses
bah moi je dirais comprise qu'en fait
des images
quand même ça va circuler
même pour les plus âgés
[Musique]
une boule de cristal
tous les jours le jour où il y a un
départ
n'importe quoi
tu veux faire parler
tous les jours le jour où il y a un des
parents d'élèves d'un des camarades de
classe de tes enfants en supposant que
ton ex
istent vraiment à toi envers moi
quelle heure il est normal en fait que
les enfants sachent ce qui se passe chez
les parents et
toi tu dis toi
tu vas comprendre ce que tu veux
j'ai rien compris
j'ai une fille de 21 ans j'ai un fils de
18 ans je suis à poil dans un canapé
dans un canapé
Amandine elle a un côté enfant qui est
très en souffrance il faut avoir
comprend oui mais c'est ça
mais je peux pas faire une analyse
devant tout le monde merde défaillante
ma chanteuse je te parle de son histoire
j'ai compris
un cheminement mais qui a fait un de
avant on devait parler toutes les choses
donc tu vas écouter je t'ai dit c'était
sûr qu'avec dire elle m'a dit pas la
même chose si attention ne change pas
les choses je t'ai dit dans le couloir
qu'on devait tout analyser jusqu'à
arriver à ce que tu voulais toi d'accord
tu as toujours pris soin de mes enfants
parce que c'est vrai que c'est très
agressif en fait et même avec beaucoup
de bienveillance on dirait que vous êtes
sa maman et je comprends pourquoi parce
que vous la voyez comme une petite fille
oui
comme j'avais dit question qu'on leur
pose pas c'est à mon avis pourquoi
ce choix moi je n'ai rien compris à
enfin pourquoi il y a autant de
d'énervement
c'est juste parce qu'il nous aime pas
c'est des choix souvent qu'on fait quand
on est jeune quand on a la vie devant
soi qu'on peut faire des erreurs et
c'est vrai que vous arrivez à un stade à
un âge où vous avez plein d'enfants vous
êtes passés sur TF1 vous avez construit
quelque chose et c'est vrai que c'est
assez rare de faire ses choix vos âges
donc la seule question c'est pourquoi
et pourquoi parce qu'en fait c'est
quelque chose qui nous épanouit déjà
depuis longtemps
[Applaudissements]
mais ça c'est important
[Musique]
on peut faire plein de choses pour
l'argent et pas forcément être
exactement donc à la fois d'accord et
peut-être le besoin de notoriété
en fait c'est un choix tout simplement
et là il faut l'entendre alors c'est
vrai que les esprits étriqués et très tu
le saisis j'ai envie de dire ne vont pas
l'entendre parce que c'est un choix qui
nous épanouit moi
parce que c'est vraiment un mec bien et
c'est vrai que on ne choisit pas sa
famille et on choisit pas le job de ça
c'est une chose alors
un truc Clara pardon
c'est pas une question d'acheter une
question que vraiment pardon un certain
moment vos jeunes iront sur Internet et
verront c'est ça voilà
les images à toi parce que là on a
l'impression
qu'elle les prennent tes enfants
parce que quand je fais ces choix là
j'ai j'ai pas conscience en fait déjà
que ça va me suivre toute ma vie j'ai 19
ans justement
mais c'est pour ça qu'en ayant cette
famille en ayant moi en ayant jamais
tu peux la vivre de façon très épanouie
avec ton mari tu peux faire plein de
choses pour t'épanouir mais pas
forcément pour les caméras
descendre et et Amandine il reste 30
secondes donc dites-nous parce qu'on
avait tellement parlé quoi bon je vais
répondre à Clara alors déjà
effectivement c'est un choix qu'on a pas
fait à 19 ans parce que 19 ans j'étais
vraiment célibataire avec un bébé
qui n'était pas Alexandre alors que
Monsieur Montiel a dit que il n'était
pas son papa il est il l'a adopté
légalement donc je pense qu'en tant que
chroniqueur et par rapport à quelque
chose avec qui serait intéressant quand
même de vous renseigner avant d'avancer
des choses parce que Léo ce qu'il a pris
désolé bah merci merci de dire que vous
êtes désolé madame donc là en faisant ce
que vous avez dit vous
ici les enfants adoptés et les parents
adoptant mais donc c'est pas bien Clara
je vous réponds je crois que vous allez
répondre demain parce qu'il est 21h17 il
y a moins que je dis non mais je vous
dis
effectivement moi à 19 ans j'étais maman
célibataire
j'ai une enfant une adolescence cabossée
on le sait et aujourd'hui
bonjour Aujourd'hui oui
Alexandre
donc c'est fini là effectivement on a le
on a le choix et en fait on a fait ce
soir
c'est l'essentiel si vous avez fait
choix c'est votre choix comme disait
Évelyne Thomas qui fait et voilà il y a
les Ken sur le canapé